yo tengo la suerte me imagino que como
muchos de ustedes aquí de para el
proyecto tiene que ser a una tribu a
muchas tribus a muchos equipos y una
gran comunidad en los últimos meses de
este año hemos digo hemos porque soy
parte de estas tribus hemos tenido
muchas situaciones solamente vamos a
empezar nativo de mi familia por un mes
vivimos en una sola habitación mientras
reconstruyen toda la casa
un niño con ameba otro niño con
influenza dentro del ámbito profesional
he encontrado muchísimas situaciones
donde he tenido hemos tenido que
encontrar soluciones diferentes un poco
esperadas hemos tenido en la comunidad
perdidas muertes enfermedades muchas
cosas que realmente nos causan estrés
que nos impactan
entonces no le sorprenderá yo conocida
como un poquito filósofa no que todos
aquí podemos ser filósofos que la
pregunta que me tiene en la cabeza dando
vuelta a todo este tiempo es cómo se ha
sentido del caos
para visualizar un poco mejor le
presento una línea pero no una línea
derechito no el garabato el garabato es
la primera etapa que pasan los niños
cuando están en su desarrollo artístico
y es un poco como este garabato que
venga aquí le produce un poco de caos
cuando lo ven quiero
que sepan que muchas veces en la vida
todo se siente caótico quiero que
piensen en sus vidas ahorita qué cosas
sienten que le da cause puede ser sus
relaciones profesionales de madre de
padre con empleados con sus familias
violencias traumas y situaciones
económicas
de todo
y nos preguntamos que estaré haciendo
bien estaré tomando la decisión es
correcta con mi vida entonces los
humanos tendemos a hacer algunas cosas
cuando vemos el caos como algo que le
tememos algo que no nos gusta de manera
desagradable no como hacemos sentido de
este caos en nuestra vida mi madre desde
chiquita siempre no tenía una adivinanza
y era como constante siempre la trae a
colación si tienes un león un chivo y
una paca como pasas de un lado del río
al otro lado del río sin que el león se
como archivo el chivo la paca a veces
del caos bueno es un poco así como
sobrevivimos como es una batalla
constante una cosa de barata la otra
nunca hay un balance perfecto
les adelanto que me encantan los libros
infantiles lo colecciono desde toda la
vida la razón que me encanta y esto lo
he descubierto a través del tiempo es
porque tiene la capacidad de contarte
algo muy importante de una manera muy
breve los temas que los filósofos más
grandes pensadores más grande de la
historia entonces cuando pienso que
hacemos los humanos para resolver este
caos para buscarle solución al caos el
primero que se me ocurre este libro
huergo vengan a ver antes era el libro
favorito de mi hijo thiago cuando tenía
un año y es una familia hermosa una
tribu hermosa que decide que vaya a
buscar un oso en una aventura y cada vez
que se encuentra con una traba o una a
ver si la grama o el lodo un río y la
familia dice no podemos pasarle por
encima no podemos pasarle por debajo
solamente podemos atravesar los
y la razón que esta historia me llama la
atención y me hizo pensar en en el caos
es porque la primera cosa que hacemos
como individuos es paralizarnos o pelear
pero es un instinto natural el humano
está creado para pelear o para asustarse
paralizarse con estar corriendo para
otra dirección
no hay que no hay nada que hacer no
puede subirle por encima del caos no
puede irse por el lado ni por debajo
solamente puedes atravesarlo
y esa es la primera cosa que hacemos los
humanos cuando nos encontramos con una
situación que lo vemos de manera con
miedo con temor
no sé si le pasa esto ustedes a mí me
pasa a cada rato me ha pasado cuando
tengo una situación que veo que me
estresa digo si yo fuera más autoritario
como este o más humilde como el otro más
decisivo como esta otra persona para ese
puede se puede resolver mi problema el
que sabe todo ella que sabe todo bueno
eso me hace pensar en otra historia de
niño que se llama el mixto que me vende
caro y es sobre un camaleón que ve
muchos animales se encuentra con
elefantita y yo quiero ser como un
elefante y obviamente con su gran
capacidad de cambio se convierte una
parte de su cuerpo en elefante luego con
el flamenco y con el humano y va
cambiando su cuerpo completo luego
pasa una vez una pequeña mosca y se lo
quiere comer
pero su cuerpo no sólo permite porque se
ha pasado la vida imitando emulando a
otra persona y ya no sabe ni quién es su
ser auténtico imagínense ustedes vivir
su vida tratando de resolver el caos de
tuyo
siendo tratando de ser otra persona en
qué momento perdiste quién era tu ser
auténtico
y esta tercera es la que más me llama la
atención porque no lo hacemos como
individuos sino lo hacemos como cultura
como sistema
cuando te detienes unas luces de navidad
los bombillos lo primero que quieren
hacer es de señalarlo y creen que el
caos de la vida se puede hacer lo mismo
se lo tratamos de convertir este
garabato en una línea derechista un
patrón y porque no se viene del lugar de
amor tú quieres que tus niños que todas
estas personas que siguen alrededor de
ti tengan una mejor posibilidad de salir
exitoso de los problemas que le va a dar
la vida entonces creamos creemos que
creamos una línea derecha
y la convertimos en una carrera
a ver hay un libro
eso es una carrera humana es que
pregunta y de manera muy cómica va
diciéndole a los niños
el niño se preguntan quién es mejor yo
voy a ganar puedes ganar el otro kick y
yo estoy preparado porque esté
compitiendo contra mi hermano llegue mi
competencia quiere que va a ganar como
que me estoy ganando esa es la pregunta
que te estás ganando y
lo veo mucho lo pienso mucho de mí desde
mi perspectiva de educadora en el ámbito
escolar es que la cultura intenta
desenredar el caos
imagínense el preescolar es la monje el
momento para prepararte para básica todo
el tiempo ahí preparándote para básica
en básica te preparas para secundaria en
secundaria para la universidad y la
universidad para trabajo y los pasos que
vienen no en la vida
y para mí pensar que no solamente tú no
puedes ser tu ser auténtico en tu vida
personal pero que la cultura te está
creando un patrón que este es el patrón
nuevo otra manera esa es la manera de
seguirlo es una tragedia humana
cuando competimos cuando nos ponemos a
competir uno contra el otro reaccionamos
de manera de batalla buscando el grial
inexistente cuál es el final cuál es el
propósito a qué vamos no
entonces le tengo un grado ya que el
caos no se resuelve podemos intentar de
desenredar estas luces pero no se va a
desenredar el caos existe y no se puede
descartar no hay ningún patrón que
podamos hacer podemos ir seguir creando
lo por lo que estamos haciendo y
diciendo toma tu causa es diferente que
el mío pero esta es la única manera de
lograrlo
será posible poder aceptar el caos y
dejar de tratar de enderezar la línea
para todos permitiendo que cada
individuo haga su propio camino ojo
en mi tiempo de educación realmente yo
tengo una visión muy alternativa de lo
que es la educación desde pequeño creo
que deberían los niños seguir su propia
pasión y no sea algo que la sociedad te
imponga y lo digo para que entiendan mi
limitación y mi visión
para halloween este año me disfracé de
jinjiang de blanco y de negro y mi hijo
de 4 años me dice mami de que tú estás
disfrazada y que yo para vivir de
jinjiang de blanco y negro lo bueno y lo
malo mira y estamos nosotros
me dice y tú que eres a mi buena o mala
yo le digo bueno mi amor yo soy buena y
también mala porque mira una cosa no
existe sin lo otro
y él me dice bueno mami yo creo que los
malos también son buenos porque mi hijo
ha estado está el vestido de ironman
bueno porque los malos sin los malos no
podemos tener los buenos entonces no
podemos tener no puedo ser un superhéroe
existen los superhéroes y fue un pequeño
momento de lucidez pero me hizo sentir
muy bien como madre porque pensé que es
que él podía haber un poquito de la
perplejidad de la vida la complejidad de
la vida porque lo bueno no existe sin lo
malo lo la luz no existe en la oscuridad
la felicidad no existe en la tristeza
y ese es nuestro causa cuando tratamos
de desenredar esto
no es posible yo no puedo sentir alegría
sin saber lo que se siente estar triste
yo no puedo ser buena sin saber qué se
siente ser mala
es una ilusión la ruptura de nuestra
humanidad
ahora le hago una pregunta a ustedes
cuando fue la última vez que se
atascaron a un punto que no podían creer
que ninguna otra perspectiva podría ser
real que solamente la suya podría ser
real
el otro día yo me topé con un libro que
yo no conocía antes se llamaba se llama
todos vieron un gato y es sobre un gato
que va caminando por la vida son lo
único que hace el gato pero las personas
que lo ven los animales que lo ven cada
uno lo ve de una perspectiva diferente y
me hizo cuando estaba tratando de darle
un poco de sentido al libro y darme
cuenta que realmente dependiendo de cómo
vemos las cosas le vamos a aplicar un
filtro si yo fuera un ratón y yo viera
toque y me diera mucho temor y así veo
las cosas que me crean temor si yo soy
un zorro y veo el gato lo que quiero es
comérmelo batallar vamos para adelante
si soy un ave lo veo como un puntito en
el paisaje y me doy cuenta que también
dependiendo de la etapa que estamos en
nuestras vidas
entonces escogemos una manera rutinaria
de ver
la vida y me dado cuenta personalmente
que yo la veo como una abeja así como
puntitos tratando de hacer conexiones me
toma mucho tiempo hacer las conexiones y
si estoy negativa la veo como si fuera
un pedazo de vidrios y todo se ve medio
turulato y yo ahí como escribiendo
poesía degollador a la vida nada se
entiende pero sí estoy positiva bueno
veo más como estrellitas y trataste una
constelación de hacerle sentido a las
estrellas y se lo digo porque ese es mi
limitación de ahí vengo yo pero la
pregunta es cómo estás viendo el mundo
tú cuando fue la última vez que tú
decidiste ver el mundo de otra
perspectiva cambiar la tuya
como experimentas lo que tú crees que es
real
muchos filósofos siempre están han
estado averiguando qué significa la
realidad que es la realidad
immanuel kant específicamente dice que
depende del filtro que tú veas entonces
para mí ha sido muy útil tratar de ver
la vida de encontrar mis limitaciones de
encontrar mi perspectiva porque sé que
existen en el mundo de esta manera puede
ser que pueda intentar otra puede hacer
que pueda intentar verlo como si yo
fuera el ratón de la situación o si yo
fuera el ave de la historia y puede ser
que eso me cambie y me ayude a ver cómo
está viéndolo la otra persona
a mí personalmente me ha ayudado a poder
entender un poquito cuáles son mis
limitaciones
y una figura que me ayuda es el delta el
cambio el triángulo que simboliza la
cosa que se puede mejorar la cosa que
pueden cambiar y de un lado tengo la
tesis la tesis es lo que yo creo que es
porque si no hay otra opción está así es
la vida así ese es el problema yo de
esta perspectiva no salgo la antítesis
es lo contrario lo opuesto de ésta
y le invito los invito a tomarla en su
mano examinarlas a ver es posible que
estas dos ideas no existan
que puedan tener una sola idea en común
y esta es la síntesis y luego la
síntesis que es la unión de los dos
puestos se convierte en tu tesis y
encuentra otra antítesis y así se llega
a la creación la innovación pensar de
manera diferente a lo que piensas hoy
así se crece como adulto y saben que
solamente 1% de las personas en el mundo
logran de los adultos en el mundo logran
a vivir así pudiendo ver todas las
diferentes perspectivas las ves
yo tuve la suerte de poder ser
estudiante de working en que es el gurú
de las etapas de desarrollo del adulto y
lo que a mí me llamó la atención y la
razón que estudiar con él es porque yo
estudio trabajo con niños de hasta 18
años y lo que yo había entendido era que
los adultos no crecíamos la
neuroplasticidad de nuestros el cerebro
al 18 año va bajando pero lo que él me
enseñó no se enseñó fue que realmente
tenemos la capacidad como adultos para
seguir creciendo pero resulta que 65% de
nosotros no quedamos en la primera etapa
de los adulto que es la etapa 3 los
orioles line y la razón que no quedamos
ahí es porque creemos que somos la
cultura en que pertenecemos que ésta es
la única persona que podemos ser esta es
la única cosa que la única cosa que
funciona que y no es que está mal porque
tu familia y tu cultura todo lo que
tienes alrededor de ti te dan ideas te
ayudan te dan opiniones es importante
saber lo que las personas de dolor de ti
te recomiendan no estoy diciendo que
estén equivocadas
pero no lo escogí este tu si tu crees
que no hay otra posibilidad si tu crees
que así es la única manera que puedes
vivir tu vida y responsabilizar a otro
de tus decisiones de quién tú eres de tu
persona de tu identidad entonces no vas
a poder crecer como humano
el 1 por ciento es un poco más difícil
de entender si se puede imaginar que yo
no estoy en el 1% yo no estoy hablando
así como de experiencia pero es poder
tomar diferentes perspectivas diferentes
paradojas digamos y poder verlas y que
tu identidad fluya entre un sistema y
otro que tú no estés atado a una manera
de ser yo soy así porque si esto es así
porque si no puede ser cambiante puede
cambiar puede ser que para para en este
momento este sistema funcione pero en
otro momento no funcione poder aceptar
eso de manera continua porque todos
creemos que estamos un poquito más
avanzado de lo que verdaderamente
estamos es lo que te lleva al
crecimiento
él dice que no es que tú recibas
información y festivas información y la
pongas en tu cerebro sino que cambies la
botella en que acapara esa información
cuando organizas este caos que cambias
la botella que lo que encapsula
cuando yo le di a inmersión por primera
vez la frase que más me llamó la
atención fue esta los humanos dejan de
interesarnos cuando conocemos sus
limitaciones lo que antes pensábamos que
era un hermoso mar resulta que tiene
bordes y es un lago
imagínense darse cuenta que es el hábito
eres tú
no el otro no tú tú tienes limitaciones
cuando yo me enteré de eso para mí fue
devastador que yo no lo sé todo qué
pero realmente fue liberan té y le digo
por qué porque me permitió ser niña de
nuevo decir ya que no sé nada vamos para
adelante vamos a ver qué puedo aprender
porque no lo sé
y a veces me hago la tonta parezco una
tonta porque no me importa hacer cosas
que traigan errores y lo permito
lo acepto porque sé que es la manera que
se aprende se aprende jugando de manera
auténtica se aprende creando se aprende
cometiendo errores ya lo tangible e
intangible se vuelven algo con que yo
puedo jugar
no es que yo sea un experto
resolviendo el caos porque cuando me
llega la duro a veces
pero he podido saber invitarla a mi casa
decirle a te acepto te quiero por lo que
me vas a enseñar te quiero porque me vas
a ayudar a crecer como humano a ver
otras culturas otras maneras de ver la
vida y eso es lo que yo estoy invitando
lo ustedes a hacer hoy
como a nivel atómico cada gota de agua
es diferente a si nuestro propio cause
entonces
sí le puedo dejar con un poquito de
reflexión para el día de hoy es dejar de
creer que todos lo sabes deja de creer
que el patrón que tu cultura que tu
lugar de estar te ha trazado hasta el
momento de ahora es el único la única
manera de ser porque no es así las cosas
pueden cambiar otros sistemas
ábrete a ellos y este es para mí la más
importante acepta el caos como si fuera
un juego divertido miren yo me he puesto
esta tocar guitarra delante de las
personas invita el caos a tu vida como
si fuera fuera un juego divertido no una
competencia no es un juego de
competencia un juego auténtico que lo
haces por el placer del juego
que se va poniendo más interesante
mientras vamos creciendo como adultos y
pregúntate a diario qué puede hacer que
sea de impacto hoy yo trabajo con niños
de allá a nivel de secundaria y yo lo
veo tan estresados porque dicen guau
que voy a poner en mi currículum para
que me acepte en una universidad que me
viene después que viene después y es
difícil pelear contra la cultura que
tenemos años aprendiendo entonces yo le
digo mira qué puedes hacer hoy que te
llena de curiosidad que te dé alegría
algo que tú creas bajo eso sí me gusta
busca tu pasión hablamos de proyectos de
vida pero los proyectos de vidas no se
pueden desarrollar o 18 años tú tienes
que empezar de pequeñito a empezar a
saber qué son qué son las cosas que te
gustan que te apasionan que te dan
curiosidad entonces ustedes ahora como
adultos que le interesa y sigan esta
pasión no estamos tarde podemos seguir
creciendo y la verdad y esto lo que lo
que yo más quisiera no quisiera dejar de
decirlo yo espero que a ustedes seguir
creciendo como adultos y darnos esa
oportunidad de ser niños ustedes mismos
le permitan a los niños reales a poder
también encontrar esa pasión y seguir
sus intereses sus curiosidades que
pueden parecer sencillas para nosotras
pero
si son importantes entonces ojalá te den
esta chance de obtener un impacto ellos
hoy no esperar hasta un futuro para
tenerlos y nada feliz aventura gracias